welcome back to cbs this morning for
more than a decade the pentagon has
vowed to eradicate sexual assault from
its ranks
but in our year and a half investigation
service members and their families told
cbs news the military has fallen short
this morning we are focusing on the case
of army staff sergeant
morgan robinson her mother says the
military's handling of her daughter's
assault
ultimately led to her death she spoke
with cbs
evening news anchor nora o'donnell as
part of her exclusive investigation
morgan robinson knew from a young age
she wanted to join the military
when she turned 21 she said mom i got to
talk to you
and she told me then that she had joined
she'd been in the army national guard
six years
when she was sent on her first
deployment to kuwait in 2016.
what happened to morgan while she was
serving abroad when she was in kuwait
she was sexually assaulted and
continually harassed
by one of her superiors
did she report it yes she reported it
what was the response when she reported
it nothing
she got nothing while on that same
deployment
morgan was sent to afghanistan where she
was sexually assaulted
again an alleged gang rape involving
multiple fellow soldiers
do you think she was afraid to report
what happened in afghanistan
yes ma'am she was very scared why do you
think she was afraid to report those
rapes
because they threatened her number one
and number two she knew that
it wouldn't go anywhere nothing happened
in kuwait with the sexual assault and
the harassment
so why would they do something you know
in
afghanistan in april 2018
then secretary of defense james mattis
said there was zero
tolerance while battlefield casualties
are a reality of war
we will accept no casualties due to
sexual assault
in our military family four months later
morgan died by suicide you pray that it
that's not how it's going to end up it
wasn't a matter of
if it was a matter of when the army
launched an investigation into her death
i tried to take a look at the copy of
the investigation that
you got here it is yes
that's it that's i don't get it it's
just blank page after blank page
they they gave you this yes they gave
you 100 copies of
of blacked out pages yes i just didn't
understand
how they could actually stand there and
look me in the eyes
and hand that to me does it make you
believe they're trying to cover
something up
of course at the time a principal policy
adviser to the military sexual assault
program
reaffirmed the pentagon's commitment to
hold itself accountable
the department remains committed to our
goals of ending sexual assault in the
military
providing the highest quality response
to service members and holding offenders
appropriately accountable
but what debbie found in the unredacted
pages of the report into morgan's death
told a much different story the
investigation into her death says
sergeant robinson suffered sexual
physical and psychological trauma while
deployed
the sequelae of this trauma was a factor
in her death yes
so they acknowledge it yes in your
opinion
what led to your daughter's death the
military the way they did not handle
what happened what needs to change they
can't police herself
how can you investigate yourself you
can't
eight months after morgan's death her
command issued the officer who assaulted
her in kuwait
a written reprimand if i was a
commanding officer
and if i had kids what would you think
if that happened to your daughter or
your son
what would you want to happen to them
are they just going to sit back and
it's okay they would want justice also
everything just plays over and over and
over in your head thinking did i miss
something could i have done
something you know you're a mom that's
what you're there for is to protect your
kids
and i couldn't protect her the army
declined our request for an on-camera
interview
but said in a statement they conducted a
full investigation
and took appropriate action against the
reported perpetrator
what do you want people to know about
what happened to your daughter to know
that she was doing a job
a job that she loved it was for her
country and to think
that that's what took her life that's
what broke her
they wanted her body and they took her
soul
think about that they took her soul
according to her mother now the army
told us that their thoughts and prayers
go out to the family and friends
of staff sergeant morgan robinson gail
they say they're committed to stopping
sexual assault and supporting
victims but there are still so many
questions left out there
i'll say those stories tell another
thing i i can only think of the
desperation and fear that morgan must
have been feeling
do you know any of the additional
details of what happened to her
yeah i mean her mother tells us um that
she did not report
that assault that alleged gang rape in
afghanistan because she was
terrified she was terrified after what
had happened in kuwait when no one would
believe her
when nothing happened and the numbers
back that up i mean the military does
studies on this
and one of the military studies says
that 64 of women who reported an assault
say they were retaliated
against after so you think the right
thing to do is you know what let me
report this
let's hold this perpetrator accountable
and then what happens to the victim
they're retaliated against they're
harassed again
and that's why we really wanted to tell
the story of morgan robinson
and others nicole burnham last night
because these women
who volunteered to serve our country
are then retaliated against for doing
the right thing by reporting these
criminals
alleged criminals and then they end up
being severely traumatized
and died by suicide i thought morgan's
mom raised a good point how do you
police yourself
how do how do you come up with an
investigation when you're the ones who
are in charge of the investigation
i know you and your team have been
working on this for a long time kudos to
your team by the way
what else do you have coming up yeah
it's a good point and
and the producers on this part of our
cbs news investigative
um team have spent so much time digging
through all those papers that what i
held up to show you the reports that are
just blacked out and redacted
that's part of this investigative work
that goes on and sort of trying to tell
the story here
gail you put the you hit the nail on the
head can the police
can the um military police themselves
that's the question
that really is the question is this a
cultural problem that exists in the
military or is it a systemic problem
where you can't report up the chain of
command
because it's not working does there need
to be an independent outside body
that deals with these reports of sexual
assault so they can handle it
independently and objectively and
certainly that's been the discussion
in congress congress is going to focus
on sexual assault and harassment and
abuse in the military because of the i
am vanessa guillen act
you remember vanessa guillen from fort
hood and many people do know
how she was so brutally murdered so
there's a shot a spotlight being focused
on this and the question is whether
there should now be
a me too movement in the military yeah
well listen whether it's systemic or
cultural what we do know it's a problem
and they need to do something about it
thank you norah thank you something
tells me things will change after this
thanks a lot
cbs news four-part investigation
continues tonight
on the cbs evening news with nora we'll
hear from survivors of sexual assault in
the military
in their own words and then tomorrow on
cbs this morning what nora learned from
whistleblowers
hired to work inside the military sexual
assault program
about the problems they saw with how the
can how the cases rather were handled